I didn't know is this true you were
engaged Allison Mack
oh God TMZ runs this whole information
about me and and that that you know I
was engaged to her while that Nexium
stuff was happening so I started getting
all these social media engaged to her uh
according to TMZ and I'm like well so
you weren't engaged I'm like I don't
know that she I worked with her but you
never really knew her no no no no so
here's the deal the fans really liked
our relationship on the show so I was
aware that the fans were like we think
that they're actually dating in real
life and I'm like oh great they're
spreading rumors about that but whatever
okay fine then that story took on a life
of its own I I had my publicity team
write TMZ and essentially say hi you
didn't do your due diligence this is
going to harm Sam's ability to get work
and if you can't provide one
photograph of these two people in public
retract your goddamn story or we're
gonna sue you and TMZ then suddenly
started issuing retractions and then the
little sites issued retractions